um i am freaking out that you said all
of those things about me i am nerding
out so hard right now
oh i'm so glad that you feel that way
because it is
a love letter to how you've
really built this career
in many ways on your own and
on your own terms you know you are
the only female in the late
night juggernaut world how does that
feel it's exciting and it's
humbling because obviously it's a huge
honor to be the first
or only anything but i'd be lying if i
said it didn't come with a lot of
pressure you know
a lot of critique a lot of trying to
meet people's expectations so
really it's just the journey of me
learning how to be my authentic self
doing what i think serves me and my
audience best and learning a whole new
world so it's
it's a lot of everything personally and
professionally to be honest
you really are the person who creates
the tone does the writing and the
producing and
has a part in the directing and you play
all these different characters
you really are in charge of your own
destiny
how do you collaborate with other people
when you're getting
notes and critiques and figuring out
what's working and what's not what's
your process because i'm in the same
boat
you know what for me it's really
important to kind of take the reins of
my creative because i do know that i am
a minority on screen i do know i have a
very specific point of view and a very
specific voice and i want to make sure
that comes through
however i have to balance that with
being open to feedback
and criticism especially you know i talk
really really fast
and so if nbc comes to me and says slow
down a little bit i need to not be a
sensitive artist and i need to say okay
that's a good no
or if they say hey this joke was
repetitive i need to not be a sensitive
artist and take that note so
it's finding the balance between voice
but being open to collaboration and i'm
so grateful because nbc has been
great at collaborating thus far i love
hearing that because whatever problems i
endure on this show i feel like the ones
that have to do with me
like people are like turn down your
volume a little bit or like do this or
do that or we want less of this more of
that
i feel like i can control that because
it is within me
i can't control the pandemic i can't
control that we don't have a studio
audience i can't control all those
things
but i can i can have a hand in making
the
best show in this environment that i can
possibly make
and you are the same way what made you
change to the house environment
such an interesting call love it by the
way for sure like you mentioned you know
during the pandemic most late night
hosts were like i need to get out of my
house
back into the studio and i was like
reverse i want to go into a house
because it just feels more me
you know my career was very could very
much be described as diy
i made videos in my house i've always
had this
friendship rapport with my audience
where they i feel like i can
hug them through the screen and a house
just feels right for that you know i i
think
we're on at 1 30 in the morning i want
people to feel like they're hanging out
with a friend
so we walk through the house we don't
have an audience but the crew is kind of
like my audience and it's just a lot
more me drew
it's like we're not doing takes because
i mess up if i don't hit the mark we
embrace it we make fun of it
i walk around in my spanx i make fun of
myself it's like a great
time just with friends and i don't think
we could accomplish that in a studio
i love that you are self-aware and
astute to make that kind of a call and i
was so excited to talk with you
because as a woman who loves comedy and
talk and
i was on instagram for years just
talking to myself you were
breaking glass ceilings in youtube and
showing what was possible i have
such a fascination admiration for you
lily
i think what you're doing is incredible
thank you i appreciate that so so much
i don't know if your second producer
told you this but i feel like as
a younger person when i watched never
been kissed it actually
really molded a part of me to become who
i am today
i think the reason i'm so about kindness
online
you know against cyber bullying about
just welcoming people in
is because when i watched never been
kissed it was the first movie i watched
where i thought
i actually feel a pit in my stomach
because of
the portrayal of this character and this
is making me want to be a better person
and i can't say that's true of any other
movie i've watched as a kid so you
literally
your performance has made me who i am
today truly i just want to tell you that
i'm glad that i could have something
in my body of work that speaks to you
because
everything you're doing speaks to my
core values
being true to yourself self-generating
not waiting for the phone to ring but
creating those
[Music]
opportunities
you